I've actually been hanging out with
Rosanne a lot recently uh one of the
great privileges of my life was taking a
flight back from her from Tim pool show
and I'll just I'll give you the like R
Rosanne is even more Rosanne in real
life yeah and she is the least
pretentious person I know which makes no
sense cuz she's in a position to be
she's far more of a legend than either
of us will ever be and we had like 15
minutes to get on the flight so we're at
a restaurant she's trying to eat quickly
we on time so she takes the sliders and
and Fries puts some ketchup on and
napkin brings it to First Class I'm like
you know bringing the class the first
class and the Rosanne is the only person
who I feel comfortable making fat jokes
about to their face because she's not
fat anymore yeah no that was so I'm not
hurting feelings so she goes you know
after after I've been stepping my face
all day like a pig I'm going to go home
and take a long nap I go as a pig she's
like so it's she's an absolute treasure
and she has a new podcast which is
superb I've been on it you know she uh I
think they invited me on the podcast we
I was pretty close with her for a while
in La we've sort of lost touch somewhat
since but uh one night we were at a
party little that and she's like you
want to get in my Tesla and I'd never
been in a Tesla before we get in her
Tesla we're in a residential
neighborhood she's like watch this and
she presses the ludicrous mode button
which they don't have anymore you
remember what that was they were
literally like a Space Balls ludicrous
mode where the car would just explode
but you're only supposed to do that on
the highway but she did it like in the
mid middle of a residential
neighborhood she's a Austin now she's an
absolute absolute oh she got La she got
out La wow good for her another one she
lives in a good
good